we've got a voicemail number it is two
one nine two david p you can call in any
time here's what someone said who did
call in yesterday by day this victim
from northern michigan the home of the
rampant free range that's called
republican and i am just so sick of
these horrible ridiculous governmental
regulations ruining business that these
eve cigarette labeling on these products
that make them look like children's
candies the free market should decide if
he's children are going to buy my
product or mom now got it that what the
regulations are just just destroying me
i can't believe it i think that
government regulation on my product oh
my what am I gonna do holy crap he's
kidding by the way okay he's obviously
kidding he doesn't really think that the
free market should dictate whether
e-cigarettes are appealing to little
kids he it's just it's a total joke but
it is funny because we always hear from
the anti-regulation right that the free
market will naturally regulate itself
even if that means little kids starting
to use e-cigarettes and dying off such
that they never end up be producing and
thus it just kind of naturally works
itself out you know yeah that was fun I
mean was that an Alex Jones impression
do you know I I think it's just like a
crazed anti-regulation right winger
parody or sort not really good I liked
it great bonus show for you today become
a member at join pakman.com or a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
to get instant access to today's bonus
show